[Music]
luke is with us in little rock hey luke
how are you
hey dave i'm good thank y'all for having
me on sure man what's up
so i made a pretty boneheaded risky move
but i'm coming out on the good side of
it i bought a farm
a couple months ago and i bought it for
undervalue and i just got an offer on it
that's going to leave me
with at minimum 100 000 maybe 130
depending on how much
my deductions go on taxes um i'm 25
my wife's in school right now um and i
make about 75 000 a year and
she's and we have we owe in the house we
own 165 on the house
and we own 100 on our school so my
question is is
what do i need to do with this money um
i don't know
i know i know i need to get out of debt
but should i
should i live my life and and work
through the debt or and just invest this
as though i'd never gotten it
um and then reap the benefits later or
what do i need to do
luke you said how much you're going to
make off this 100 did you say
at least yeah at least okay
well if i woke up in your shoes um
uh once you get the money from this
after it sells and taxes are paid and
it's all
in the clear i would immediately pay off
your student loan that's the only debt
you guys have right is that 100
100 000 in student loans uh we have
about a five thousand other loan for uh
for a medical bill
okay perfect yep i would just knock all
those out so you'll be completely debt
free
100 percent after sales form which is
amazing any other cash that you have
i would open up a small money market
accounts or a money market account
um and put the rest in there because
that will get you close to probably your
baby step
three which is three to six months worth
of expenses
so having cash in the bank you have that
already how much do you have
there uh about 40 000.
40. okay well i'd go ahead and just
throw that at the 100k
the student loan debt right now i would
i would clean that out keep a thousand
dollars for your emergency fund
so the goal here though lucas to is to
get this debt paid off
as quickly as possible and then on the
other side of it with your numbers you
guys are going to have
a savings of three to six months of
expenses um
and then you guys can move on to
investing but i would use the money not
to invest right away like you said i
know it sounds like a good idea let's
just put it in the market
and forget i ever had it and you wake up
65 you're like oh i'm a millionaire
because of this money because the sell
the sell the farm but listen if you
don't clean up what's going on in the
presents
that's going to sneak up on you so get
that cleared get some money
for your emergency fund and then you can
look at start investing at that point
so okay great that's that's what i
thought i needed but i just
i just need to hear it from someone else
yeah let's the baby steps
are the process we've developed over
this 30 years that is the shortest
distance between where you are in wealth
the shortest distance between two points
right straight line and so
that's what rachel did she just walked
you right up the baby steps and so we're
gonna clear the five thousand dollars in
debt today
write a check when you get off the phone
get rid of that medical debt
we're gonna take everything but a
thousand and throw it at the uh
at the student loans and then we'll
finish the student loans off with the
sale of the farm
now you've got a couple of issues um one
is
the the farm deal even though you came
on the show knowing that
we wouldn't have gone along with the
crazy idea of going into debt and hoping
you can flip this thing and
make money and yet it worked and so you
have
you you're the guy that walked up to the
slot machine
and dropped two quarters in and made 200
right it's going to be real hard to not
do that again because you think that's
going to happen again
some part of your brain still thinks
that works and you didn't you didn't use
that part of the brain when you were
talking to us you discounted it
but be careful just say i'm not the guy
at the slot machine
because you're going to go do this crap
again if you're not careful
well the level of anxiety that i felt
over buying and
and realizing i needed to sell as
has kind of pushed me away from that but
there is a there is a small bit of me
the great news is it worked the bad news
is
it worked right and it might make you
want to do it again okay so that's the
danger
now when did you when was the closing
date on the purchase of the farm
about three months ago so i know i'm in
long term or i know i'm in short term
capital gains
which means ordinary income and so if
you clear 100 net
40 of that's going to the government
yeah
so you barely have enough to clear your
debt after taxes
and your emergency fund so that's where
you're going to end up
unless you've got something else going
on we haven't talked about but that's
right where you
are man so you're you're a wise young
man to have recognized that you got out
with your skin
intact uh and i i hope you don't do a
repeat because i'm saying that because
that's the kind of crap i did
i would go well you know maybe i'm the
exception to the rule maybe gravity
doesn't apply to dave you know it turns
out gravity applies to all of us right
so i always think i'm the one that can
get away with it there's a level of
arrogance i mean
pride goes before the fall the bible
says and i man i just i've fallen all
over the place and i'm not saying that's
you i'm just
i'm susceptible to that and so that's
why i always warn everybody else
and i think naturally people just have a
higher risk tolerance than others
you know some people are like i just
want that and then some people are like
i i it there's something about living on
the edge
that they thrive on i mean honestly
though there's a level of that
24 years old we go on a first cruise
we've never been on a cruise we didn't
know what that was
and your mother is the most risk averse
person
on the planet saves every nickel and she
dropped two dadgum quarters in a slot
machine and hit 200 bucks oh so this was
a true story it's a true story
and you know what that 200 bucks cost us
500 because she put
every quarter she got for the next week
into that dad gum sloppy shame this
she's as risk averse as you get
but she fell for you know your brain
goes
i know it's rigged i know that they make
more money on it than they make put out
i know in your brain your intellect says
don't do it but your emotions going i'm
the exception
and you just keep putting oh god man and
i've done that
so many times and i'm not risk averse
risk doesn't bother me
but even your mom and you know you know
sharon's not sharon's not she's not a
wristband
but i'm saying in general sure a slot
machine or playing some crafts in vegas
i mean like every now and then yeah or
you know anybody did that i won though i
did yeah see there we go there we
go what are you your father's daughter i
paid for half my
vacation with my friends and i even had
it in an envelope i really did
you're making my point for me but but
what i'm saying is i'm not talking about
that because that's like just i'm not
talking about that but i'm saying though
people's lifestyle with their money
though there are people i talk to and
they
they get a thrill oh i know out of
losing money on living on the edge of it
i mean
they do because it's a dopamine whatever
yes yes stupid
telephones just gotta keep the dopamine
going
keep the smartphone happy check 63
000 times a day how many times you check
your email today how many times have you
checked your email
five thousand times at least while we
were on the air i thought
oh my god